[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen crêpes fällt meine
lieben freunde für euch ist es jetzt
zwar nur eine folge später für mich
besteht allerdings ein zwei wochen
abstand zwischen der letzten folge
minecraft mit luca da wo wir uns das
bettchen hingestellt haben und hier das
dorf entdeckt haben und der jetzigen
folge die ich jetzt gerade aufnehme denn
ich war im urlaub und haben mich im
urlaub auch einfach mal fett erkältet
negativ
gibt es direkt wieder schön reiten
alltag enorm urlaub wir werden
zuallererst in der heutigen episode uns
mal das dörfchen hier ein bisschen
genauer angucken hier vorne befindet
sich keine kiste drin laufen wir hier
vorüber wären auf jeden fall einige will
ich weiß nicht was du bist
geistlicher
haben wir eine kiste auf jeden fall am
start und zwar kartoffeln löwenzahn
brauche ich nicht aber das nehme ich auf
jeden fall mit einigen sätzen kann ja
auch mal gebaut kommt den löwen sein
können wir uns
ja jetzt gehöre mir hier vorne haben wir
einige bücherregale die können auch mal
mitnehmen die kann man auch immer ganz
gut gebrauchen das lesepult benötigen
wir nicht ich habe auf jeden fall noch
ein zuhause und hier oben ist nichts am
start dann haben wir allerdings noch
einige weitere häuser denn hier vorne
prallen die zwei dörfer voneinander
werden irgendwie diese art von häusern
und wir haben hier fordern diese art von
häusern haben
ich habe halt auch schon frau stand aber
gut wir schauen mal weiter was wir noch
so haben wir haben hier noch die kirche
da könnte ich auch noch mal ganz genau
auf diesen brauch stand drin wir vorne
noch eine kiste und hier vorne haben wir
auch nichts am start der körper ganz gut
warum mache ich das immer auf jeden fall
brauche ich mir hier vorne nochmal die
weißen blöcke habt dass wir uns daraus
machen können und das weizen dann
nachher wenn wir wieder zu hause sind zu
broten umwandeln können die sache ist
allerdings meine lieben freunde ich habe
für heute noch ein kleines ziel
beziehungsweise einen kleinen planen und
zwar habe ich ja in der letzten folge
ein gefährder entdeckt und ich dachte
mir wir haben noch kein richtiges pferd
auf unserer insel von daher nehmen wir
heute einfach mal als und da hinten
haben wir schon direkt so ein gepflegtes
fährt rumstehen von daher ganz langsam
anschleichen man muss glaube ich um ein
pferd zu zähmen einfach nur hingehen und
rechtsklick drückt es hat geklappt
perfekte gar nicht geklappt eine stunde
später
[Musik]
gemeldet wir haben fährt
wie weit sich das nicht aus um ein pferd
in minecraft steuern zu können benötigt
man einen satan kein problem dar denen
habe ich zu hause vergessen die ist
allerdings auch nicht weiter schlimm
denn ich würde das pferd dann einfach
mal kurz hier stehen lassen und mich mal
zurück nach hause bewegen
und da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause angekommen ich mag mein brötchen
jetzt einfach mal direkt hier vorne an
der kleinen billiger insel so dass ich
mich direkt von hier aus ins baumhaus
bewegen kann und eine runde schlafen
gehen kann und dann müssen wir uns jetzt
als nächstes auf jeden fall den sattel
holen den hab ich ja hier vorne am start
einer sollte da denke ich mal ausreichen
die sache ist allerdings
der ist tot
die sache ist allerdings dass ich erst
einmal nur ganz kurz mit der lore fahren
muss und zwar dauert unten aufs fest
dann beziehungsweise auf die andere
seite und da sehen wir auch schon dass
sie jetzt der bus kommt das ist nicht
unser kleiner highspeed ic strecke habe
ich die einmal angekündigt und jetzt
[Musik]
ich hatte
wir schieben das hühnchen hier jetzt mal
ganz kurz von der strecke runter und
shops unsere lage hier runter setzen uns
rein und wir sehen schon wir fahren mit
highspeed hier durch unseren
unterwassertunnel und
ihr seht schon gefahren die mit
highspeed durch unseren
unterwassertunnel unter vorne gleich
auch mit highspeed wieder nach oben und
apropos highspeed meine damen und herren
ihr wisst ja dass ich vor einigen wochen
bereits mit der formel kooperiert habe
und jetzt am kommenden wochenende findet
der bmw i berlin epd
2021 statt ab kämpfen die besten 24
fahrer und zwölf besten teams um den
titel im letzten rennwochenende mega
spannend falls ihr also noch keine
tickets für die vollelektrische
einsitzer rennserie besitzt dann könnt
ihr diese nur unter diesem link hier
kaufen oder halt einfach dem obersten
link in der infobox hier unter dem video
und mit dem kot luca 15 hatte die nummer
15 prozent rabatt ich freue mich auf
jeden fall extrem zum aller ersten mal
bei einem formel ehren mit am start zu
sein jetzt am wochenende in berlin und
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja dann auch
mit etwas glück vor ort allerdings würde
ich sagen machen jetzt erstmal weiter
mit minecraft und zwar fahren wir jetzt
hier rüber auf die andere seite und ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich mensch
luca warum sind wir denn jetzt überhaupt
hier rüber gefahren das ist eine sehr
gute frage denn ich habe ein video
entdeckt was wir vermehrt zu gesendet
wurde ich will es allerdings noch nicht
sagen um was es in dem video gingen weil
ich das selber erst mal austesten wollte
meiner welt und es klang mir ein wenig
zu viel versprechend sage ich mal hab
ich mein brot noch mit drei perfekte
einfach boot nicht mit dabei bin
schwimme ich einfach in ganz europa das
wurde mir nämlich unter anderem die
kommentare geschrieben wurden aber auch
bei instagram geschrieben ihr könnt ihr
auch gerne folgen und zwar hat es etwas
mit diamanten auf sich und ich weiß
nicht ob man im ganzen braten trauen
kann allerdings muss man sich für diese
taktik wohl in einem sumpf befinden und
den habe ich ja hier vorne am start wir
fangen jetzt wahrscheinlich luca warum
außerdem ist er da hab ich benötige das
ganz einfach damit ich mich da ich
trocken runter bauen kann denn das hat
auch etwas mit trocken zu tun und zwar
trocken beton
mega nichts hat was mit ton zu tun meine
eine schaufel ist jetzt gerade kaputt
gegangen von daher mache ich mir mal
ganz kurz mit der werkbank noch eine
weitere chance also zusammen und dann
haben wir hier die schaufel am start die
bergmann nehmen wir selbstverständlich
damit wir lassen ja keinen müll in der
pampa rumstehen und jetzt müssen wir uns
um gucken nach ton in unserer welt und
ton gibt es auf jeden fall hier woran
das
bin ich bin jetzt gerade hier vorne hier
vorne hier müssen ich gebe sprachen
lernen hier vorne haben wir auf jeden
fall schon mal so eine ton anordnung die
ich gesucht habe und zwar ist das hier
ja die mitte von diesem thonberg also
hier vorne von daher brauche ich hier
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
erde drum herum so dass wir das ganze
hier trocken abbauen können also hier
vorne noch einmal sport so rum und dann
können wir uns jetzt hier in der mitte
vom ton perfekt runter bauen und jetzt
soll man sich wohl so weit runter bauen
bis man angeblich hier in sub millionen
in der mitte von ton direkt auf
diamanten stößt es kann auch sein dass
ein paar blöcke weiter entfernt sind wir
mal ganz kurz hier grüner hand dass ich
ein bisschen was seht aber
ich bin gespannt ob das klappt 20
sekunden später
[Musik]
ich habe nie wieder auf
ich höre verdammt nochmal nie wieder auf
euren scheiß trips wir sind auf jeden
fall wieder oben angekommen und wissen
nun dass diese taktik vielleicht
funktioniert wird
ist auch egal wir wissen auf jeden fall
dass die taktik bei mir nicht so gut
funktioniert ich weiß gar nicht wo ich
hergekommen
euch mal eine ganz kurze time nach hause
laufen
denn hole und zurück zum pferd laufe
[Musik]
leute bei mir hätten gerade wieder
komplett kopfschmerzen
ich weiß nicht wollte eigentlich mit der
lore jetzt nach hause fahren
perfekt und da wollte ich nur haben ich
glaube die lasse ich sogar mal ganz gut
stehen dann kann nicht erwartet man im
dieser lore mit so und dann fahre ich
mit der häme zurück und zack ich weiß
dass ich eigentlich jetzt nach hause
laufen wollte mir den sattel holen
wollte dann wieder zurück zum pferd
fahren wollt aber das pferd auch 67
minuten weg mit dem boden dann hätte ich
das wieder zurückholen müssen und blabla
von einer würde ich das tatsächlich auf
die nächste folge verschieben einfach
aufgrund meiner gesundheit gerade
aktuell ich weiß ich bin selbst schuld
ich bin dumm und war bei kalten
verregneten wetter in der nordsee ich
bin da einfach ein juli von daher hoffe
ich dass ihr verständnis dafür zeigt
dass ich dir heutigen episode minecraft
mit luca an der stelle jetzt schon
beenden werde ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
lange wir sind ich bin eine aufnahme bei
circa einer stunde allerdings möchte
wirklich fit fürs wochenende jetzt in
berlin und da freue ich mich wirklich
schon mega drauf von daher weil er
lieben freunde wenn euch die heute ja
diesem einkauf mit luca gefallen hat
dann einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr die nächste
episode minecraft mit luca nicht
verpassen wollt soll die übermorgen
schon online kommen oder erst in vier
tagen wird übermorgen anderes video
sehen was soll ich überhaupt im nächsten
video machen schreibt es mir dann alles
unten in die kommentare ich hoffe ich
bin bis dahin ein bisschen fitter und
ich jetzt instant schlafe mit litschi
[Musik]